I want to start today talking about this
little thing called the Constitution
Donald Trump his team his staffers his
supporters they've been carrying on
about the rule of law and the
Constitution and how under their watch
we are going to have the rule of law in
this country we're going to have law and
order and if I say to you the rule of
law in the United States the definition
of it is general but also precise in a
way the rule of law is quote the
restriction of the arbitrary exercise of
power by subordinating it to well
defined and established laws the
arbitrary exercise of power keep that in
mind in our country just because law
enforcement says you did something or
thinks that you did something before a
particular punishment is carried out
before the allegations are put into sort
of a final decision phase there is a
process of the law and when it comes to
undocumented immigration if law
enforcement thinks someone came to the
country illegally you still have a legal
process which confirms the circumstances
and looks at the facts and only when
that has been refereed by the justice
system do you move forward with for
example the punishment of deportation
I'm ignoring by the way that there are
two justice systems in the u.s. one for
the rich one for the poor but for this
story that's not actually the main focus
Donald Trump said yesterday that he
wants people who come into the United
States illegally deported immediately
without any judicial process Donald
Trump tweeted quote we cannot allow all
of these people to invade our country
when somebody comes in we must
immediately with no judges or court
cases bring them back from where they
came our system but weird weird grammar
but we understand what he's saying our
system is a mockery to good immigration
policy and law and order
he actually mentions law and order
in a tweet calling for the total
elimination of the rule of law and this
is what we would call unconstitutional
this would violate due process and there
actually is some debate among
constitutional scholars a group to which
Donald Trump doesn't belong in case you
weren't sure about that constitutional
scholars do debate the extent or degree
to which all aspects of the Constitution
apply to non citizens to people who are
here illegally or to people who are
residents but not citizens but there is
no question that cancelling trials for
suspected undocumented immigrants is
completely unconstitutional the Supreme
Court has already decided that anybody
in the United States whether you're here
legally or illegally you are entitled to
due process of law it goes to the second
half of section 1 of the Fourteenth
Amendment and it's very clear that it
applies to all persons there are parts
of the Constitution and the Bill of
Rights that make a distinction about the
rights of citizens versus the rights of
all persons but there is no question
whatsoever that there is a right to due
process for people who are in the United
States regardless of how they got here
so there are people online now let's
take a step back supposedly trumpets and
Trump and the right are advocates of the
Constitution they are defenders of the
Constitution they say we like Trump
because he will enforce law and order
and the rule of law
so the constitutional right should be up
in arms and absolutely furious about
this idea from Donald Trump because it's
a direct violation of their stated value
of defending the constitution but I
check the forums online I went to the
normal enclaves of bottom-feeding
pond-scum
online and they're loving this idea from
Donald Trump here are some examples that
I came across quote if they're illegal
we don't need to waste time and money
with courts just get them out another
comment correct as usual about Trump's
idea of just kicking people out with no
due process and quote he is correct
illegals have zero rights here get them
out the Constitution doesn't
work this way and I am I have a call-out
I'm formally putting the call out right
now patent make a note of this please if
there are any so-called constitutional
conservatives who are ready to stand up
and say this cannot be allowed to happen
I am going to put party aside and say
this is an attack on the basic
fundamental tenets upon which our
country is based let me know because I
want to hear from those people it's
actually is surprising in a way because
conservatives always argue that due
process point on the topic of guns yeah
like sometimes will be a push to take
people who are on the no-fly list or the
terrorist watchlist and make it harder
them for access to gun guns and even
maybe take the guns away conservatives
say that would violate their due process
it's exactly right because being put on
a list is not a judicial adjudication of
any kind right you appear on a list and
all of a sudden you lose rights that are
granted to you either by statute or
court precedent or the Constitution and
Bill of Rights that would violate due
process they say well then this
absolutely would and I actually am
curious even going beyond I think the
ship has sailed with most so-called
constitutional conservatives who support
Trump they're going to come up with some
reason to either just ignore this or
defend it but what about government
agencies are there government agencies
that would actually be doing what it is
Trump is suggesting here that are going
to be willing to stand up and say we're
not going to do it because whatever our
political disagreements are about
immigration policy or quotas or country
of origin or whatever even if you think
we want people from Norway and we don't
want people from Guatemala like Trump
has suggested you can still say but
we've got to do what the Constitution
says I hope that there will be
government agencies that do that I'm
sure that the heads of those agencies
will very quickly find themselves fired
by Donald Trump however it'll come down
to the individuals that the respective
agencies I think just like with the
child detention Fiasco there will be
some whistleblowers some people who take
a stand and say we're not gonna go
through with this others will go along
with it I think you're probably right I
think you're probably right and this is
a this is a direct attack on the
Constitution and I wish that we could
get beyond partes
ship whether it was Obama was accused of
doing this stuff of course he wasn't
actually doing it Trump really is right
there were no FEMA camps under Obama
there really are child internment camps
under Trump President Obama wasn't
trying to suspend the rule of law Donald
Trump is actually saying get rid of due
process altogether and just start
kicking people out on the say-so of I
guess Border Patrol agents I don't even
know who this is a crisis and we
actually have multiple crises to talk to
you about today